stroll down the cereal aisle at any
grocery store and you'll finds a myriad
of choices for starting your day healthy
been unhealthy packed with sugar or
packed with bran was certainly not
wanting four options the idea of a
breakfast cereal industry is one that's
taken for granted in today's modern
worlds but it's a surprisingly recent
idea with a bizarre history Kellogg of
course is one of the first names that
comes to mind when the conversation
turns to breakfast while official
Kellogg's history notes that it was WK
Kellogg who founded the company first
known as Battle Creek toasted cornflake
company and to hired their first set of
44 employees it was his brother
dr. John Harvey Kellogg who was the
driving force behind the development of
the breakfast cereal and it's a tale
that they definitely don't tell you on
the back of a cereal box
there's devout religious teachings a
condemnation of sex and fulfillment of
natural urges a deep-seated distrust of
conventional medicines and a faith in
radical treatments that today seem
nothing less than barbaric on one hand
Kellogg was driven by a need to make the
world a better healthier place but on
the other hands he also liked dabbling
in things like eugenics and promoted the
idea of sterilizing people that he
deemed undesirable he was a complicated
individual showing us that the world
since indeed history is full of people
who do the wrong things for the right
reasons and sometimes an entire business
empire can be built on their shoulders
to truly understand who John Harvey
Kellogg was we have to start with his
parents John Preston Kellogg ins and
Stanley were farmers but they were also
devout individuals who were living on
the cusp of the foundation of a new
religion in 1852 they were introduced to
the beliefs of a new religious movement
that was spawned from events that took
place or more accurately didn't take
place on October the 22nd 1844 that was
a very important date for a group called
the Miller ID since they believed it was
the day of a very literal second coming
they believed Christ was going to return
to walk the earth once again and when he
didn't the date became known as the
greatest acquirement religion is of
course complicated and difficult to sum
up quickly but the gist of the story is
that Christ's apparent failure to return
to Earth divided his followers some
followed a woman named Ellen Harman who
claimed to have experienced a prophetic
event in December of that same year she
said it had been revealed to her that
the date was right and she had been
given a sign that they needed to
organize and travel the straight and
narrow paths or right into heaven the
group was following a set of rather
disorganized beliefs and teachings when
the Kellogg's were introduced to the
movement and it wasn't until 1863 that
they organized into the seventh-day
Adventist Church
by then the Kellogg's were already well
established in the movement having
helped relocate the group to Battle
Creek Michigan John Harvey Kellogg was
born in 1852 and was front and center in
the burgeoning seventh-day Adventist
movement when he was just 12 years old
co-founder James White who had marriage
the prophetic Alan Harman invited the
young Kellogg to learn all he could
about the printing trade with the
ultimate goal of getting him to aid in
the spread of their teachings via the
printed word Kellogg was fascinated by
both the teachings and writings of the
new movement but also by other works
earlier health reforms had been
preaching things like temperance
abstinence and vegetarianism ball in the
name of living a life that would bring
the mortal human closer to God and that
fell right in line with what the
Adventists were just beginning to teach
this was the beginning of Kellogg's rise
to the attention of Adventist leaders
and in order to make sense of what comes
later in his life it's important to
focus on where he was coming from and
what beliefs he was building on so
day adventists tradition says that
people have a moral obligation to lead a
healthy life taking care of the physical
form they say is the only way to
guarantee complete service to God and
living the best healthiest life possible
includes things like forgoing alcohol
and tobacco but there was a bit more to
it in Kellogg's day Adventist leaders
were critical of conventional medicine
and wanted to train their own group of
doctors who would have beliefs rooted in
Adventism but experienced in practical
medicine that would allow them to be
critical while speaking from a
well-informed position so Kellogg was
recruited as one of a group of people
sent to study at the first high GI
therapeutic College in New Jersey then
later at the University of Michigan
Medical School Kellogg didn't aspire to
be a doctor in the traditional sense
instead of treating illness he wanted to
help prevent it he earned his MD from
New York City's Bellevue Hospital
Medical College in 1875 and by that time
he had already published a cookbook
focused on improving dietary habits
authored safe work on the importance of
vegetarianism and took a position that
he would hold until he died as editor of
a monthly Adventist periodical he later
named good health
[Music]
in 1876 Kellogg was appointed the
superintendent of a facility called the
Western health reform Institute which
was quickly renamed the Battle Creek
Sanitarium over the next few decades
Kellogg and his brother will which
oversee the development of this
Midwestern facility into a globally
recognized destination part resort part
medical facility and part retreat of the
rich and powerful that's not an
exaggeration either at the height of its
popularity the facility welcomed between
12 and 15 thousand new patients each
year and some of those faces changed
history among the patient list were
names like Henry Ford Thomas Edison
Johnson Rockefeller Warren Harding
Booker T Washington and such an a truth
even Amelia Earhart stopped in for a
little R&R before major flights a
practice that came to be known as taking
the Cure the facility was impressive and
impressive as putting it mildly in
addition to a 15 story tower with 1,200
bedrooms there were hundreds of baths a
lobby the size of a football field
indoor gardens and to give you an idea
of the scale of the place there were a
full 5 acres of marble covered floors
the sanitarium had its own power plant a
staff of doctors nurses orderlies
masseuses and at the head of it all was
the good doctor Kellogg who met with
each and every patient who got off the
train and was delivered into his care by
livery coachman it sounds absolutely
brilliant sure but here's where things
start to get a little bit weird Kellogg
sanitarium was outfitted with all the
equipment that he could possibly need to
get his patients in tip-top shape
but treatments weren't necessarily ones
people would be thrilled to be
prescribed one of the most popular rooms
was the sanctum sanatorium which was
filled with and yes this was a very real
thing enema machines each machine was
capable of pumping 15 quarts of water
you know where in just a single minutes
and if there's anything that will
encourage you to reach for that
high-fiber cereal it is that in extreme
cases where that wasn't enough to get
patients having their recommended for
bowel movements per day a number Kellogg
reached after watching aids they were
prescribed a yogurt first a pint of your
per day was added to the patient's diet
then they were given a yogurt enema so
you might be wondering well why and that
answer would be cleanliness Kellogg was
obsessed with it
take those marble floors for instance
they weren't there for appearance's they
were there because they were a surface
where germs and vermin can never find a
lodging enemas weren't the only commonly
prescribed treatment that patients could
expect to experience Kellogg was also a
proponent of lice therapy and he was the
inventor of something called the
electric light bath essentially patients
were put into a cabinet and lit with
light bulbs and it was thought to be a
cure for a number of ailments everything
from writers cramp to syphilis it's also
worth noting that this one isn't as
far-fetched as it seems at first glance
some of Kellogg's work laid the
groundwork in using light therapy to
treat depression Kellogg was also
interested in the healing powers of
electricity and prescribed a regular
sinusoid or current treatments to some
patients particularly those diagnosed
with tuberculosis and lead poisoning the
Marg electric currents were applied with
the help of a device that he made
himself from a telephone and sometimes
the current was supplied to the skin and
sometimes it was applied straight to the
eyeballs in an attempt to treat ocular
disorders and that wasn't the only
machine he invented the sanitarium was
filled with devices that would shake
vibrate slap and even beat patients to
various ends some were designed to
stimulate the bowels others were thought
to improve circulation and some of the
good doctors wealthiest patients had
their own versions of his machines
installed in their homes Calvin Coolidge
even had one in the White House during
his time as presidents it's also worth
noting that people loved it going for
treatments at the clinic affectionately
known as the sand just a few years after
Kellogg took over he went from treating
300 people a year to 1200 and the
numbers kept climbing he truly believed
in what he was doing and even advertised
in major magazines to help get word out
about his miraculous treatments an
advertisement ran in Good Housekeeping
in 1907 and boasted of the 46 different
kinds of baths at Kellogg's disposal
some were ordinary like foot baths some
where odds like light baths and some
could only be described as extensive
patients complaining of ailments like
chronic diarrhea various skin conditions
and mental illnesses would be prescribed
a continuous bath so what was a
continuous bath it was just a normal
bath taken in a tub but a patient could
be instructed to stay there for days or
even months the more you think about it
the worse it gets but that wasn't the
worst thing Kellogg ever prescribed that
dubious honor belongs to his cures for
what he called the solitary vice
masturbation masturbation he believed
would ultimately lead to things like
heart disease and insanity so to stop
patients with a chronic habit he did
terrible things boys would be bound tied
or forced to wear cages and if that
didn't work they would be circumcised
without anesthetic in hopes that the
pain would discourage further acts girls
were not exempt either and some were
burns with acid or subjected to surgery
to remove part of the genitals Kellog
was devoted to health and to godliness
and he was certainly extreme amid these
cures Kellogg focused on something that
he believed desperately needed an
overhaul breakfast
this is when we go back to the heart of
Kellogg's seventh-day Adventist beliefs
co-founder Alan Harman white wrote that
the truly devout would follow a
vegetarian diet because fruit and
vegetables were seen as God's gift to
mankind she taught the people should eat
foods that could be consumed in the
natural state fruits vegetables nuts and
grains Kellogg followed that belief at a
time when breakfast was about as
unhealthy as you can imagine Kellogg
remember was living at a time when most
people started their day with the
previous night's leftovers some of the
most common breakfasts involved meat and
potatoes reheated in a pan with whatever
fats they had congealed him heavy meals
of salted and cured meats were also
popular and anything grain-based was
difficult it was time-consuming and
labor-intensive and it meant getting up
before the Sun stirring and cooking raw
grains integral in 1858 Walt Whitman
writes that indigestion was the great
American evil and there's no wonder
gastrointestinal distress was so common
and so frequent that there was one
catch-all term used to describe all of
the symptoms dyspepsia Kellogg's
attempts at overhauling breakfast were
practical he wanted something that was
easy for someone to prepare and just as
easy on the stomach he and his brother
spent years experimenting in their own
food lab trying to come up with
vegetarian diets that would be easy for
any patient to digest and that were
boring the boring part there he was on
purpose part of the theory was that
bland boring food would not only keep
their patients walking the straight and
narrow right up into heaven by consuming
food the way God meant it but also that
it would prevent them from getting too
excited and overstimulated they did have
some success starting with proto's it
was essentially an early version of a
veggie burger it tasted of peanuts and
was both given to sanitarium patients
and sold through mail order he also
developed something called granular
until another 19th century foodie
claimed the rights to it and forced him
to change the name kellogg's granula
bars of cornmeal and oatmeal that were
baked then ground into bits became known
as granola just sell the Kellogg
brothers made their leap into cereal is
a bit of a legend and a bit of history
and the story goes that they mistakenly
left wheat berry dough on the counter
overnight it was stale the next morning
and when they rolled it out and toasted
it they got some crunchy flakes that
became a huge hit with patients Kellogg
handed the marketing of their breakfast
foods off to his brother who was working
as the sanitaire
Ariane's bookkeeper but all was not well
at Battle Creek Sanitarium debts were
mounting church elders were concerned by
a curriculum they saw as getting far
away from their seventh-day adventists
roots and when a fire swept through the
compounds they told him they wouldn't be
rebuilding at the same time Kellogg's
brother will was pushing a practical way
of getting more people to buy their
cornflakes he wanted to add sugar an
addition that Kellogg found a horrid
will left founds the Battle Creek
toasted cornflake company and Kellogg
tried his own hand at selling the flakes
that invented together will sued one and
went the business route while John
Harvey Kellogg stayed on at the San it's
also worth a quick aside here to say
that Kellogg wasn't the only cereal
company to come out of this era one of
Kellogg's recurring patients was a man
named Charles William Post who stayed at
the sanitarium in the 1890s during
periods of mental breakdowns and stress
he saw what they were doing picked up on
the trends and went on to sell the
cereals Postum and Grape Nuts through
his own company Post Company is
generally credited as being the force
that pushed Kellogg's you've developed
better products with a longer shelf life
and as for the competition Kellogg would
comment that he was not after the
business I am after the reform that is
what I want to see Kellogg held his
patients to strict rules and that
included sticking to his bland
vegetarian diet and a requirement that
they chew a lot a devotee of horace
fletcher he prescribes you theories of
flat sure ism that dictated chewing each
bite of food forty times would aid in
digestion
he was often heard leading diners in
singing his chewing song and there is a
bit of a footnote to this not all of his
patients were happy with the dart and
philosophy of no alcohol and no smoking
fortunately for them that particularly
brilliant entrepreneur asset of a place
just down the street called the red
onion tavern and served steaks cigars
and whiskey to patients along with the
promise to get them back out the door in
time to beat the sanitariums 11:00 p.m.
curfew
[Music]
while Kellogg spent much of his life
working in the Battle Creek Sanitarium
meeting with patients while wearing a
distinctive and clean white suit with a
cockatoo on his shoulder there was more
to his life than just a never-ending
parade of patients he married
eller Eaton in 1879 and while they had
no biological children they fostered
more than 40 kids and officially adopted
several she played an invaluable role in
his dietary experiments and she also
introduced him to new social spheres of
influence like the women's Christian
Temperance Union he was also an adept
surgeon spending some time studying
abdominal surgeries in London and Vienna
by the time he finally put down his
surgeon's scalpel at 88 years of age he
had performed around 22,000 procedures
Kelo kanaday falling out with adventist
church leaders in 1907 and was
ultimately expelled from the church they
believed that he was using Church funds
for medical research and education
instead of evangelism and it was in the
France that they could not stand for
Kellogg still kept control of the
sanitarium though rents in addition to
remaining a consistent controlling
presence there he also expanded its
reach to open schools for hygiene
nursing home economics and physical
education on sanitarium grounds he
served on the Michigan State Board of
Health right around 50 books on the
subject of Health issued some of the
first warnings on the dangers of smoking
and this is about to take a strange
twist because he went on to co-found
something less than admirable the race
betterment foundation this was exactly
what it sounds like an organization
dedicated towards maintaining the
superiority of certain races by
selective breeding remember all those
children that he and his wife fostered
it wasn't entirely out of the goodness
of his heart as the eugenics archives
notes that most of the children were in
one way or another deemed undesirables
Kellogg was hoping to make some sort of
discovery on the influence of
environments on heredity and don't worry
it gets even worse the Battle Creek
Sanitarium was at the very center of the
spread of eugenics throughout the US
during the early 20th century and
Kellogg devoted about 30 years of his
life and a ton of his own money to the
idea that excluding people with certain
genes from the pool of breeding humans
would improve humanity as a whole
so we exclude them how while he was
serving on the Michigan State Board of
Health he successfully lobbied to pass a
law that would call for the
sterilization
mentally defective persons Narwhal that
led to the involuntary sterilization of
at least 3,800 people in the state
Kellogg hints are the believers preached
that encouraging only certain people to
reproduce would end all of the ills that
the human race suffered from from
poverty to criminality and to quote
feeble mindedness this superior race was
of course the Caucasian one and yes
there was a very real association that
would later form with a Nazi Party
Kellogg began to completely embrace
eugenics after his falling out with the
seventh-day adventists group who
incidentally believes that all life was
a gift from God he became obsessed with
the idea that if things continued as
they were mankind would begin to decay
and degrade in quality until finally it
simply ceased to exist in 1914 Kellogg
had become good friends with other
leading figures of the eugenics
movements like Charles Davenport founder
of the eugenics Record Office they held
the first race betterment conference at
the San and one of his guest speakers
was a former patient Booker T Washington
he was there to try and talk to
attendees and convinced them that
everyone should be treated fairly and
equally thus and incidentally was always
a segregated facility conference
attendees did more than just examine and
measure around 5,000 children as part of
the better babies contest they also made
it clear that they were going to start
pushing their ideas further into the
u.s. the second conference was held in
1915 at the Panama Pacific International
expedition and it took the society's
beliefs clearly illustrated by charts
highlighting the differences between
superior and generous races and put them
squarely in front of 18 million visitors
he campaigns for the establishments of
nationwide legislature similar to what
had been established in Michigan and
even proposed registry where people
would be given pedigrees and patients
who fell within the established
guidelines for racial hygiene would be
eligible for awards there were a few
things that brought down the eugenics
movement and the first was the extremes
of Nazi Germany even before that the
troubles brought by the Great Depression
proved too many the poverty and hardship
had nothing to do with genetics but
eugenics legislation it was still in
place and sterilizations were still
practiced into the 1970s as the Kellogg
he died in 1943 he nearly hit the
century he had always proclaimed
he would live - he was 91 years old so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe also please do check
out our sister channel Geographics if
this channel is about people that
channel is about places it is linked to
below as always thank you for watching
[Music]